jr パーティーん
[音楽]
んんん
ああ
a la ここで使う日約0
ございません前場はようわ
セク冷めちゃう受けたセグウェイターズで高校のえっと同級生
黒パスゲームでねー一番だから
よかったというと思うだろなんで一番で1回悩んだめって何
ブーブー sarena ちょいーっつもぬ4メンバーはちょっと
[音楽]
ブービーからティパドゥん
軌道とある距離からやろ風ちゃいま県のスポットです
ある掲示板に書いてあることを作ればから8日いこうと思いますぜ負けの小矢部市と
いうところにあって
石川県の近くなんですけどもあこれはや晴れ
倶利伽羅トンネルは異次元につながってるぞや yeah
やい去年のひっかく的あったかかった12月の終わりに
一番の放火が入ってといえば間に抜けたら一面雪景色
スタッドレス履いてなかったから死ぬかと思ったぜ
踏ん張るますこれこれはこれ貼って倶利伽羅峠に行ってきました
最初は
何も感じなかったのですがその酒に進むと嫌な気を感じましたゾクゾクする感じだっ
けー
気が強いて気持ちの問題や6ここはかなり気が強いと思いますやはりか酒た心細いかな
よ
どうぞはーい今日は
倶利伽羅峠にことなんですはぁっ
全貌際の案内によると展望台とかある
今でもムサの霊が出るとのことですね武者に安心院ショップんか
方など方など音聞こえる出場の坂本はしラインあんまり
ギャ目ついやつ
だから一条6坂本が良い奴やからってここにいる坂本か良い奴は限らんよ
だけど俺は少なくともやつは持ってる俺は妥協っていいやという
俺は参加もたい奴は俺せてる
俺は the 香水屋と思ってりゃはでるんやじゃあねーよりああああいい奴じゃない
よ
ありがとうえー何か地下気にせんぞー
関ヶ原のただけでなくゆっくり頃通り佐世保で系だという
歴史上に名を残した戦いが俺らに住んでいることがあったらすよねすごい校
よしここに来ていれば最初これいっ破道元すごい雪です
これが雪国でございますああ
voodoo これはウードゥー
ranran
街灯が少なくけれどどうにもつけなくなってきました
セクシャルおるやろだいぶこうやってみましょう有名が怒るで今回の該当な40円狙い
東第8回表6ライトないってうん
うーん何
とうとう明日なぁかこれでを通ってダメだったりするんですか
うん[ __ ]分ねそう確か歌うよだから青い時はとますよねでもでも時間時間べくないっ
てだからなんて書いてあるか竹ちょいーっ
あれはちょっと私らー達 a べからずにゃんぱいぱてぃんだかそれっねあーそりゃ
ペロス
空線がおいしいことでブーツおらずソラリー道するとする
ございまああああバイバイ
年雪結構入った結構いけなくなったんだろ結構濃い黒槍でおおっ
けどさーん
エアーやばいやばいやばい花はこれやばいわー
これやばい敦也のばいる夏の本アーム後か地熱やああ
青函てる平瀬が鉄はぴ安い韓国
何も強いこれからも保育入ってるねーーあんかけうかチーム月光じゃこれやばくの警告
ですねぇー
こあいなった警告が今日たち目の後継国から釣れなきゃいけございません
[音楽]